you hosted the golden globes is it five
times your school groups five times over
ten years yeah okay yeah because i don't
know if you guys know you probably don't
know that the golden globes have just
sort of vanished they didn't they didn't
happen this year for for loads because
of you because yeah i'm getting i'm
it changed as well because the first
time i did it like 10 years ago the sort
of press particularly the industry press
in america was like how dare why is he
saying these awful things to the most
beautiful people you know and then by
the fifth time right they were going
good give it to him we're sick of
celebrities
so it was quite zeitgeister it sort of
hit a mark last time and that but i'm
really glad i did it but i think that's
enough okay you must were you in the
audience for any of ricky's golden
globes several times
it was a little bit i think it cuts to
you in one of them i think when you talk
about geoffrey epstein i don't know why
yeah to me
but it's a little bit like the
experience of being in the room with you
at the golden globes is a little bit
like the tail end of a family christmas
yes where you know it's drunk uncle yeah
drunk yeah yeah
do we show him where the bathroom is
do we just let him know i can feel that
and i can see the tension and then when
i do a joke about them they think oh
that was all right like leo gabriel was
laughing thinking he could have said a
lot worse you know
[Music]